تلاحق إيران هذا الأسبوع
صحفيين أبلغا عن وفاة
السيدة ماسة أميني الشابة التي توفيت في
حجز الشرطة في سبتمبر / أيلول ،
وأثارت وفاتها شهورًا من الاحتجاجات الحاشدة
والدعوات إلى إنهاء النظام الديني الإيراني المتشدد
واتهم عملاء المخابرات الإيرانية بـ
صحافيتان بتهمة التواطؤ مع
السلطات المعادية التي يمكن أن يعاقب عليها بالإعدام ،
عُقدت الجلسة الأولى لمحاكمة أحد الصحفيين
يوم الاثنين في طهران خلف أبواب مغلقة ،
وستبدأ محاكمة الصحفي الآخر يوم
الثلاثاء
بينما خففت الاحتجاجات في إيران
السلطات هناك.  عدم إعطاء شبر واحد
لأي شخص يظهر معارضة جماعات حقوق الإنسان
تقول إن الحكومة بدأت في
إعدام المتظاهرين مرة أخرى سلمى
عبد العزيز لديها التفاصيل
خارج سجن بالقرب من طهران عائلات
السجناء المتجمعين يهتفون لا تشنقهم
مناشداتهم تأتي بينما تستأنف إيران
إعدام المتظاهرين بعد  استؤنفت
الممارسة الوحشية التي
استمرت لمدة شهر هذا الشهر مع شنق
ثلاثة شبان متهمين بقتل ثلاثة من
أفراد قوات الأمن خلال
احتجاجات مناهضة للحكومة في نوفمبر / تشرين الثاني.  لا
أساس لها من الصحة تم
إجبارهم على مشاهدة فيديو
للمحققين وهم يعذبون شقيقه
وتعرض لما لا يقل عن 15
إعدامًا وهميًا وفقًا لمنظمة العفو
الدولية في مذكرة صوتية حصلت عليها
المنظمة التي أكد على
براءته ، لا يمكن لـ CNN التحقق بشكل مستقل من
المقطع الذي
استمروا بضربي وأمروا به  لي أن
أقول إن هذا السلاح هو ملكي ، كما يقول ، لقد أخبرتهم أنني
سأقول ما يريدون
فقط ، من فضلك اترك عائلتي وشأنها
قبل إعدامه ، حاولت أسرة مكونة من 36
ياردة سامي مدرب كاراتيه من صفهان
لفت الانتباه إلى محنته ،
وانتشرت هذه الصورة لوالده  على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ، ابني بريء على اللافتة التي
تقرأها ،
لكن دون جدوى شارك النشطاء هذا
الفيديو المفجع قالوا إن
والد أسمر هاشمي يحتضن صورته وهو
يرقد بالقرب من قبر ابنه ،
ولم تستجب إيران لطلب شبكة سي إن إن
بشأن
العدد الإجمالي للمتظاهرين المعروفين.
تم إعدامهم منذ العام الماضي
يبلغ عددهم الآن سبعة وفقًا
لتقارير CNN ومن المحتمل أن يكون عدد عمليات الإعدام أكثر من
مائة متظاهر قد حُكم عليهم
بالإعدام أو يواجهون تهماً
يُعاقب عليها بالإعدام ، كما يقول
ناشط حقوق الإنسان هذا عندما تخشى السلطات
الاحتجاجات أو بعد احتجاج عدد
من  تصاعد عمليات الإعدام والهدف هو خلق
الخوف في المجتمع لمنع المزيد من
الاحتجاجات ، هل تتوقع أن
يرتفع العدد أكثر هذا العام فهو
يرتفع بالفعل ما لم
يتخذ المجتمع الدولي خطوة قوية
ضد عمليات الإعدام هذه ، فقد
نواجه  يقول عدد كبير من عمليات الإعدام
في الأشهر المقبلة
إن محمد روبرت لو ، متظاهر يبلغ من العمر 22 عامًا
يعاني من مشكلة تتعلق بالصحة العقلية ،
يمكن أن يكون أحد الضحايا المقبلين
لآلة الإعدام الإيرانية.
تجرأ على الحديث عن بعض عبد العزيز سي إن إن
لندن